hey everybody i'm here
it is labor day but we are in the studio
today
why i don't know no we're here because
we do normally take federal holidays off
but
next we're off all of next week it's the
first sort of like
full break for a while
because of the virus so since we're
going to be off
all of next week save maybe the
occasional live stream i might pop
into from any number of undisclosed
locations around the world um
we will be off from the standpoint of
the podcast
and the tv show and the radio show next
week but we are
close to hearing from donald trump uh
just momentarily
um scheduled for the top of the hour and
i think it's going to be
very very powerful and very very
interesting so we will um
be looking at that at the top of the
hour and i have things to discuss
in between now and then um
we did do a show today yeah so this is
we don't have just the stream today but
there's also a new podcast episode it's
already been filmed and it is
on route on route so that'll be
published
probably 3 p.m eastern the way it always
is
um i see a super chat from amy saying
pence is speaking peace out
yeah we pence is speaking but we're not
carrying that
um i mean we could look at it briefly oh
i guess they're both scheduled for the
same time that's funny
uh in any case we're focused in on the
trump speech we will look at polling
we will look at a lot of different
things just as a reminder we do still
have a pandemic going
on i know that some people are
pretending that there isn't one
but another 31 000 cases yesterday in
the united states we've now
we've now re-flattened the curve half of
the flattening we did before
at which point we decided to open back
up and get back up to 75 000 cases a day
so uh yeah still no vaccine
and still no particularly effective
treatment
we've talked a lot about expected
vaccine
announcements over the next probably
i i'm still thinking it's going to be
around october 15th there will be the
announcement of a vaccine
and then we will see what
uh people actually fall for and don't
fall for so we will see about that
okay matthew sends a super chat saying
streaming very strongly chakuseki
says via super chat in his first
anti-super soldier act
who do you think trump is going to
arrest first the
gazpacho gestapo or the progreso
proletariat probably the gazpacho
gestapo
would be my guess yeah over on twitch
where we now
very brightly display the number of
twitch subscribers which you will notice
dropped by about 300 since last week
because everything is on a month on a
rolling month basis
bit 101 has subscribed with prime and
says on a more positive note
subscription counts are also increasing
yeah well
i guess not so we're down 300 from last
week but that's interesting
but yes things are happening and we're
continuing to build
by the way i don't know how this
happened usually weekends are very
slow for the david pakman show youtube
channel
somehow over the weekend we had a couple
of youtube clips hit
one got over 300 000 views i don't
remember the other one maybe two
250 and we are now slated
to hit one million subscribers on
youtube
in only 17 days can you imagine now
scheduled for september 25th
it wouldn't be crazy if we actually hit
a million during the vacation and if we
do
don't worry i have all sorts of content
planned for you if that happens
um and we i showed you some of it last
week
maybe i will show you hold on here's
something i can show you that you might
like
um hold on a second yeah here it is
we are going to have a video where is
there we go
we are going to have a compilation video
where we are going to hear
from all sorts of different people who
have been guests on the show and have
had different roles on the show
and i've been previewing some some
of the people who have been speaking
like last week i showed you ben dixon's
clip
here is former producer louis motomety
delivering a message of peace and love
and this is going to be part of our
compilation which we will very
powerfully release when we hit 1 million
take a look
there is former producer lewis getting
all set up congratulations a million
subscribers that's such a big number um
monumental achievement i'm happy for you
think about that a million think about
all the effort
it takes all that subscribing i think it
would be neat to kind of get into that
so that's like uh a million subscribers
let's say it takes half a second
to hit that subscribe button that's 500
000
seconds and now we're talking lou is
taking a math approach in his message
that's like 8 33
minutes and we'll do the math here
that's uh well that's about 138.8
hours uh well a million has a nice ring
to it
there you go so a very very powerful
message from lewis there as you can see
and all sorts of different people hassan
[ __ ]
has delivered a message to me stephen
kenneth
destiny bennell the second has delivered
a message to me
a former nfl football player has
delivered a message to me
we've heard from all sorts of people
anyway we're putting all of this
together and it's going to be a really
nice compilation video
which we will publish when we get to a
million but we are not there yet
we are currently at 987
987 so just about 12 and a 12
000 and change to go okay other super
chats coming in
actually wait i have some new members to
thank tyson smith
tyson smith kicking us off with the
first membership today at
joinpackman.com
thanks tyson i appreciate that hope i'll
have other people
to thank we are keeping an eye on a
couple of different streams anticipating
donald trump at the top of the hour okay
super chat's coming in god says hey
david long time fan from dubai
when do you take calls i'm always late
to the party wednesday 12 15 pm eastern
time wednesday 12 15 pm eastern time
jr says he's gonna tout job numbers in
the economy but he hasn't done anything
to earn the credit he's played golf and
on top of that he's played golf
all he loves to do is play with little
balls
jhwh says still shocked by the rnc
next level propaganda american
patriotism is weird as it is but the
imagery and speeches put north korea to
shame well said lauren says did you see
the trump boat train in austin that
ended up with multiple boats sinking
wondering if it was karma
yeah a bunch of boats sunk and it was it
was
wild really just stupid leica says when
sam
cedar loses the million subscribers
competition to you
will you send him blue chew to help him
get his confidence back
maybe i will maybe i will sam
cedar actually delivered a message for
the million subs
compilation which i think people will
find uh
pretty interesting over on twitch we
have a lot happening we have a level two
hype train in progress
now a level 3 hype train tulmu has
subscribed and says
heck yes keep up the great work a little
punch drunk has subscribed
jerry mandering has subscribed
annie greenfield skillser
lillian so and malfunction 99 as well as
cyberx or maybe that's cyber9
bit 101 i already mentioned very good
love it love what's going on there
um okay han jo bae
come on guys han jabe says davey
what will the tone of your video be
about trump's inevitable passing
celebratory solemn just the facts will
you condemn a dead man
love you i don't wish for nor take
pleasure in anyone's death
the world can be better off without
someone around without taking pleasure
in anyone's death
i think that's important for all of us
to remember
as we wait for donald trump
nicholas d pasquale says windmills do
not give you cancer
invest in renewables invest inhumans dot
co
love the show david okay dominic
richardson says it's pretty orwellian
how trump
said all the polls are fake and then at
the same time
falsely says biden is plunging in the
same polls right
the polls don't exist and they are fake
the sources for trump saying the
military are losers
are fake and yet they are people who
aren't telling the truth
wait wait a second hold on the sources
don't exist but they're lying
sorry but i don't know
it's very weird it doesn't really make
sense thanks to
nathan shocker who is new member number
two today at joinedpakman.com very much
appreciate that
i do have memes i don't know if
anybody's interested in some memes but i
do have them
uh let's see here
other memes this is a meme about voting
i guess
vote or die what does that even mean
what you think it means [ __ ] and as you
can see
that's me that's producer pat and that's
former producer lewis with sunglasses as
well as two other gentlemen
okay i don't really get this one but
we are looking at other memes also i
think people are going to like this this
is really good
joseph woodward is a music
creator on soundcloud and
he put together an original plasma track
which this is so layer layer
one of the meme is trump and
convalescent plasma
layer two is this song and then i'm
gonna tell you layer three in a second
okay this is lo-fi plasma take a listen
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
[Music]
lives
battling a current infection
convalescent
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
okay anyway so that's layer two layer
three of this truly historic meme is
that i've asked joe to send me a version
of this track with no drums
i'm going to play the drum track okay so
once i i'm just i have one cable i need
to get my e drum
set up i am going to be adding the drum
track myself and filming it so the third
layer of this
it it's sort of um these are sort of
like convalescent
memes if if there's if i may uh the
third layer of this meme is going to be
that i will be
performing the drum track and i may have
a different interpretation
in terms of the the uh percussion
than joe had we'll listen to just a few
more seconds
efficacy of convalescence
so that's a beautiful beautiful track
and uh
we are going to be looking at that very
very powerfully once i even
uh one once i have a chance to add the
drum track to it so everybody stand by
for that it's going to be a beautiful
beautiful thing
thanks to frank drogsma who is new
member number three today
at joinpacman.com appreciate the support
very very much also thanks to perturbo
we have 40 seconds left to hit a level 5
hype train right now we've not hit level
5 on twitch
for a couple of weeks we have 30 seconds
to go
blaze king gets us a little closer
perturbo
rotch blissful terror has signed up
circle hair guy pre
a little punch drunk i think i already
mentioned
we have 10 seconds left to get to a
level 5 hype train
oh i don't know if we're going to do it
i think this may be as far as it goes
yep we didn't make it we got to level
four fair enough level 4 is not bad
other super chats continuing to come in
uh where did i leave off lake
says always enjoy your content keep up
the great work aloha from maui
appreciate that shaner says my family is
passing around a post that america's
being gaslighted
is it gaslighted or gas lit by the media
and trump is sent by god oh the sad
irony
benjamin spiegel says donald trump
doesn't know a light up the dark
skechers from a well-lit
creenus can't vote with him can't vote
without a man i don't know what that
means
aritro pathak says trump loves kung flu
t
okay loose [ __ ]
okay that one's not bad that's actually
clever david
natasha bertrand announced on twitter
the other day
you slid into her dms asking if she
wants to see photos of your 10 inch
zucchini is that real
my zooks and cukes are dead
sorry i froze there my zooks and cukes
are dead
yep something happened i believe that
they got diseased
that's with like five z's diseased
um and they died my cukes died my zooks
died what i've got going now basically
are um tomatoes and peppers
are beautifully coming in every day but
cukes and zooks died i did try to do
something convalescent with them and it
just
didn't work so i've got herbs
mint is out of control but
the my peppers and tomatoes are really
what's doing the best right now
what can you do you know you do what you
can i'm working uh it was only my second
year
sort of like really gardening okay
uh easy meacham says hey david remember
a few lifetimes ago when
ivanka got patents for voting machines
how do you follow up or track something
like that i don't remember that actually
i'd have to review that matt carlio says
pacman on the tony stark sarcasm level
today please keep us laughing
chaka seki says in general mattis's own
words the only military member blow
disrespected
is colonel sanders that's not bad
trump's penchant for kfc
i like that i might steal that and turn
that into a tweet chakuseki
i really should hire chakaseki to write
for me
because he or she is very clever
very very clever dustin brown
says i'm just coming back to following
politics after it had me feeling pretty
hopeless
appreciate the content and remember to
take care of yourself david yes indeed
we will be off next week
boom off just off next week
and i think it's going to be a really
really good thing
unfortunately we may hit our 1 million
subscribers during the vacation
but what can you do if it happens it
happens you know
not too much we can do about that
thanks to andrew andrew jaboy
and kip velcronow who have subscribed
with twitch
prime we are standing by for donald
trump
um okay i did have a few other things
oh um
okay let me do yeah i'm gonna do just a
few minutes of this
so kyle who did the original lo-fi
convalescent plasma video has also given
me a submission
for a million subs so i'm gonna play a
little bit of this for you
this this is pretty involved and i don't
want to
release all of it into the wild until we
actually hit a million but
just to give you a sense of the amount
of content that we're putting together
really i mean i didn't do this kyle did
it uh this is going to be a good one
once we once we hit a million i think
you're going to like it
i am contemplating
some possible litigation
around this clip that we're about to see
we have reached 100 000 subscribers on
youtube the david pakman show surpassed
the 200 000 subscriber mark on youtube
400 000 subscribers on
youtube 500 000
subscribers 600 000
subscribers 700 000
subscribers on youtube yesterday as many
of you know but as many of you don't
know
this program is on youtube
750 800
000 subscribers that's an eight followed
by five
zeros that's an eight followed by five
zeros the david pakman show youtube
channel
has achieved and surpassed 900
000 subscribers in fact i think we now
are probably closer to 901
i went back and looked at the statistics
for our first month on youtube
in september of 2009 we had 711 views
total and we had 721 views
777 views 720
that i don't know why that is i think
what happens is youtube must adjust
their statistics
in retrospectively by small numbers
because i'm sure i was giving the right
numbers
at the time one views and four
four subscribers we had four subscribers
we had i don't mean
four subscribers subscribers
we had four subscribers and four
subscribers three of which were probably
uh
accounts my mom made okay hit some
really interesting numbers
in our first month on youtube we had 30
subscribers
those are the right numbers subscribers
this actually isn't crazy it is uh quite
an accomplishment for us i mean our
youtube channel started
so small back in 2009. thanks to your
support
and i'm talking about the trolls as well
i'm thanking the trolls as well
it was alleged that i established
sort of a race against sam cedar to a
million subscribers
i smell bots i smell bots so look here
here it is right now
put this video up look folks ronald
reagan has just informed me
that uh david pakman has taken a lead
in our race to get to a million
subscribers
and i am making a personal appeal to you
right now hit the subscribe button
it's not necessarily where i'm pointing
to i don't know where it is maybe
maybe it's down here or over there but
hit the subscribe button
don't let david pakman steal our valor
if we can automate a lot of these tasks
that some would consider maybe mindless
some would consider
low brain activity tasks somehow
bots that i have presumably used or paid
for
right are boosting our youtube
subscriber numbers
this is a little bit of a problem
pounding that subscribe button
turning that subscribe button uh you
know all of the battle of
all this stuff we are using bots
the the growth curve has been
accelerated
my thought is i don't know that we
should be drastically changing what
we're doing in order to get to amazing
subscribers that's an amazing goal
based on the recent subscriber trends
you could have a million subscribers and
no views
and that's where our focus continues to
be
you it's not like voting where you can
only vote once you can vote for
everybody
okay i don't i i just don't even
understand what's happening right now
so uh this just as a heads up this is
all
fake it's all a joke the only serious
part
is let's get to a million and finally i
asked the leaders of the region
political and religious israeli and
palestinian jewish and christian and
muslim to join us
in
god bless you god bless israel and god
bless
the palestinians and god bless the
united st
states
all right so there's about another 40
seconds there which i am going to keep
private for now because that is going to
be debuting when we actually hit
1 million subscribers so we have a lot
planned is the point we're taking this
seriously
we're looking forward to thanking a lot
of different people speaking of which
lori green is new member number four on
my website and sebastian
orca is new member number five today
at joinpakman.com i appreciate that come
on
in grab a membership let's look at some
messages coming in this is a perfect
time
to send a super chat it will pop up on
the bottom left of your
window over there a few super chats
coming in
um oh no i don't really have any john
mannion
sent a super chat with no message oh
this is sad and
dan values said
cnru did it not trump man
that's sad i thought i had more super
chats to read but
okay some some of them are going to come
in
i'm sure i'm positive that super chats
are going to come in very strongly
i want to say thanks over on twitch to
soup can
sam for subscribing with prime as well
as
lag botch lag bocce
logbot che i don't know as well as
justin
andrew watson and um okay
i appreciate all of that thank you thank
you so much
um people want the plasma song again i
don't i don't think so we're good
let's let's wait until i add drums to
the track
but we we will have plenty of
opportunities for that
um okay what else did i have
um people asking about
venezuela yeah i don't know that that's
really the issue today
ren holder says q anon makes me
fear for the future of this world i
understand that
i understand that does anybody know if
we have any streams that are live
in the room fox news is not
and the white house is not but if we had
a stream that was live in the room i
would
gladly switch to it let's see here
what can we find is the hill trump live
maybe the hill is live
take a look they
are not live uh
washington post trump live
no
yeah right side media i'm not so sure
about
i'd rather something a little more
respectable
anyway we'll keep an eye on it let me
somebody let me know if there is any uh
any stream that's live super chats
continue to come in
james anktill says david how can we vote
for democrats after seeing this
jummy david okay i'm not gonna click on
stuff during the stream
nicholas silva's david maybe hitting a
million subscribers warrants the only
fans that possibly is not immoral or
illegal that everyone is demanding i
just don't know
about this only fans thing i know a lot
of people ask me about
when am i going to have an only fans am
i going to have an only fans i have a
cameo
and that's probably right it's probably
more on brand for me
don key dicks says did you get your
teeth white and they look way brighter
no i got a haircut though it is
conceivable that my hair was so
uh extended that it was blocking the
light to my teeth
but no i did not get a teeth whitening
now that i'm against it i just the few
times i've tried
it my teeth get too sensitive it's not
it wasn't a good experience for me
tim carlson says it's like having an
intellectual toothache listening to
trump very well said
chakaseki very much focused on soup
says first they came for the chowder
then they came for the bisque then they
came for the borscht
when they came for me there was no soup
left there would be no greater tragedy
than them coming for the for the borscht
borscht is one of my favorite soups
those of you who are familiar with my
uh semitic background probably would not
be
surprised to hear that but borscht is a
national treasure
really a national treasure thanks to
susannah coons
who is new member number six today at
joinpackman.com
i appreciate that um
imgene asks how many of my subscribers
do i attribute to sam
cedar's background inspiration
probably three three of the million i
would say
cs says the hill is live okay let's look
for the hill
the hill live
ah very nice beautiful
the hill has gone live and this will
give us a sense of how long we likely
have
um until the start of this very powerful
event oh we trump's doing an outdoor
thing this should be this is different
all right very good i'm glad to have a
little bit of a different background
thanks to political puppy for the nine
month subscription
over on twitch no to only fans we only
want your information
marinated brain i've been marinating
ideas upstairs
for for a while and i will soon have
something to present to you
uh let's see here reed larson says hey
david how long after trump is out do you
think you will be using bigly strongly
etc
um that's a good question i don't know
not that long not that long i would say
dereten says do you think trump has
affected your mannerisms only as a joke
only as a joke dinah
dino sacks dmr says david donato here
from the uk
watching trump's america the movie
idiocracy could actually become a
reality
very much so very much so
lisa kleinwart says i am very grateful
for your commentary
makes listening to trump more strongly
grateful
thank you lisa i appreciate that
this nepan fire says let's spit out
the orange trump gum november 3rd thanks
ted for the subscription
karen saunders says i wouldn't even be
slightly surprised if trump's vaccine
starts the zombie apocalypse
so i don't want to get ahead of my own
show much like
kaylee doesn't want to get ahead of
trump i don't want to get ahead of my
own show
but i have a clip coming out later today
about how perfectly kamala harris
answered a question about will she trump
trusts
will she trust trump's vaccine if it
comes out in october
and she brilliantly pointed out this is
not about
vaccines this is about we've learned not
to trust
anything on trump say so and what's so
important about this
is that if people who under who accept
the science of vaccines
start saying you wouldn't trust a trump
vaccine
you have to be really impo really
careful not to fall into this
possible anti-vaxxer stuff the issue is
not the vaccine
the issue is do we trust trump that it's
ready because trump lies all the time
and kamala i do a full breakdown i mean
she really put out a clinic
she put on a clinic of how to be
interviewed
while answering questions but taking
control of the framing of those
questions because there's two things you
very often see
when politicians are interviewed one is
they just don't answer the question at
all
trump never answers the actual question
the other side of it is answering the
question
but not correcting the framing and
kamala harris does both in this very
interesting interview with cnn's dana
bash over the weekend
and i review some of the clips on a
youtube clip that we'll be publishing
today
uh podcast tv show
radio show etc uh okay
please consider yourselves invited and
consider doing me a favor
okay this is a program where we we do
all this different stuff
and we have employees and we have health
care for employees and you know all this
different stuff
it's mostly funded by memberships on my
website
so if you're suffering from the economic
virus
that is spreading thanks to the
mishandling of the actual virus
i don't want anybody's last dollar i
don't want anybody's last two dollars
but i will ask for your support if you
are okay financially and value what we
do
head over to joinpakman.com grab
yourself a membership we have a coupon
code
right above my head 2020 now which will
just chop
66 off of the price of a membership this
is not a lot of money
we're talking two bucks a month or a
dollar eighty
if you pay for the entire year i will
thank you
profusely and all you know we we've had
our issues with youtube funding
we've had all these different the
website membership
is steady it goes directly to us
there's no middle men there's no middle
women
there's no middle people and i will
thank everybody who signs up and it
really does make a difference so thanks
to
roseanne jombrow who is new member
number
seven today that's a great person
roseanne
joe longfellow great guy new member
number eight today
who else do i have dana mills
love it new member number nine today
um i will continue thanking people and
love it love it when people sign up
remember it's also september
over on twitch and i've i've never known
anyone to turn away a nice twitch
subscription okay let's get back to your
comments because that's really why we're
here otherwise it would just be me
talking to the wall
um peter milson says nothing
okay thanks for the super chat jf
where did that go jf gambie says hi from
france
david one of my favorite countries
anything we can do here to help eject
trump
no meddling into the election meant
though what you can do in france jf
is convince someone to listen convince
someone to allow me in
i don't even need all americans allowed
in half the country
hates france as you know they think
france is a problem
i love france i would love to just hide
out in france until the pandemic is over
so
try to work on getting me into france i
would love that
ryan fulton says do you prefer books or
audiobooks i have never listened to an
audiobook i don't even have kindle i
have physical books i carry around these
physical books it's so
antiquated but i like just getting
off of all screens there's something
about the tactile nature of the book
the smell of the book which allows me to
i don't know something so i am still on
physical books as crazy
as that is i i know it's insane but i am
still on physical books
um did they just close the door i guess
they're closing it in advance of opening
the door
okay the only time i will sometimes do
a condensed version is i will do the
blinkist sort of like powerpoints
where you can page through a summary of
a non-fiction book i will sometimes do
that
sabrina zafar says visiting northampton
for the first time from boston any
recommendations
yes sabrina if you're visiting
northampton here's what you have to do
uh go to mosaic cafe
get yourself the mosaic salad with
grilled chicken
beautiful leave mosaic cafe
go to familiars which is an old train
car
turned cafe and get yourself a
cappuccino
tell danny i say hello and then once
you're done with that
this is all safe socially distant okay
it's all outdoors
then well after that then what
listen there's so many great places
amenus cafe
highbrow for pizza kisara
in east hampton if you can make it over
for sushi if you stay in northampton go
to moshimoshi for sushi great place
i wish uh well you know there's some
places that are sort of closed but yes
there's endless endless recommendations
in northampton
very very important ones chris says
thank you david keep it going
with a huge 49.99 super chat
really appreciate that thanks chris and
on that note
i want to make sure i'm not falling
behind on twitch thank yous
neisha anart naisha nart has subscribed
with prime
dolly madison says keep up the good work
and reasoned analysis pack azure
says love your show keep up the good
work thank you
uh and morph1x3
has also subscribed with twitch prime
let's see if anybody else has gone live
yet
fox news not live the white house not
live but the hill is live so we'll stick
with this
it looks like we're very close to the
start if we were able to start
within uh 15 minutes of the start time i
think it would be really great
vidar morse says what are your thoughts
on third parties in general
i'm in favor of them do you think we'll
get out of the duopoly
in order to get out of the duopoly we
need to fix campaign finance
and fix first-past-the-post voting
those are the two things that must be
fixed
a few other thank yous for people who
have signed up on my website which i
really appreciate
thanks to michael jones who's new member
number 10 today
kathleen raddick is new member number
11.
jake fournier is new member number 12.
christopher barber is number 13.
matthew bedford is number 14 greg
perlman is number 15 bjorn
thulin is number 16
and annika simmons is new member number
17. that was weird where did that come
from
uh i've got a couple more and i will get
back to those thank yous very soon
roon has subscribed over on youtube
stephen says what's the over under on
hoax utterances this briefing related to
trashing vets will it even be brought up
it will be brought up i expect trump to
use the word hoax
four times i would set the over under at
four
that seems reasonable olivia's bubble
says i'm really scared about what's
going to happen next
in the u.s things are completely out of
control and it's disgraceful
i think we really do need to apply the
teachings of the great stoic
philosophers
marcus aurelius seneca
um i don't know if it's pronounced
epictetus or
epictidus but they very
uh astutely divided they actually they
talked about the sphere of control
the dichotomy of control where the stoic
said there are things over which we have
control and things over which we don't
that's a little bit oversimplified the
truth is there are things over which we
have total control
like for example what are my goals
that's my decision and my decision
completely i have total control over my
goals
things over which we have no control
like will the sun come up tomorrow i
have no control over that
we should not concern ourselves with
things totally beyond our control
but the devil is really in the details
of those things over which we have
some control and when it comes to those
the great example is
a tennis match do i have control over
whether i win a tennis match or don't i
well i have control over whether i train
to the best of my ability and effort
i have control over whether i try my
hardest
i have control over whether i practice
for months i have control over whether i
hire a teacher
ultimately i don't have control over
whether i win and that's the analogy to
this election so
when we talk about you know i understand
the fear
we don't have control ultimately over
the results we can say
let's make every effort to get out the
vote okay
we can't we can't be disappointed if our
goal
is to make every effort to get out the
vote and we try
we can't be disappointed if we say let's
do everything we can to fight voter
suppression
if there's still voter suppression our
goal cannot be to stop all of it because
we can't control that
so my advice to people here is
uh read for example william irvine's
book
on stoic philosophy understand what is
really the trichotomy of control there's
a word for you
it's a real five head word the
trichotomy of control
and um take that approach going into the
election i think it is far healthier and
i actually addressed this today
on a um on a segment that we will be
publishing to youtube so
that's a big rant i apologize for the
rant
but i think it's important
value says free nelson mandela
okay
anita says would you ever promote
manscaping products
you use well i would promote manscaping
products i don't
use any but um like we promote bluechew
on the show
and i don't use it we're about to get an
ad that's weird this is a live stream
nobody else is live yet this is really
weird guys it's actually starting to get
really weird
anyway um
okay oh some people are liking my
haircut yeah it actually took
it actually took for once i had a couple
haircuts that
did not really take i asked my uh
hairdresser stylist i don't know the
appropriate word
if she thinks i'm losing hair because
every time i look at it i start to think
is this thing receding
and she very powerfully felt that i am
not
that's the word for my hairdresser so
you know a user with his with just a
bunch of
numbers says thoughts on maria koleni
kolesnikova's abduction i don't have any
particular
thoughts about it unfortunately
owl aquatics says does the presidency
require candidates to pass a drug
why does it say ginger on the screen
that was weird there was a subtitle that
just said ginger
is there audio here
that's weird maybe somebody in the
background said the word ginger
owl aquatic says does the presidency
require candidates to pass a drug test
no do any political offices for that
matter
uh i don't believe so
sean broderick has grabbed a youtube
membership shannon bennis hey shannon
great to see you
shannon says where did that go
uh oh where did shannon's message go
there it is
if trump releases a vaccine the two
the two of the most esteemed and trusted
orgs cdc and fda
will have compromised can they come back
from that so i'm not sure shannon i
understand exactly what you're saying
but but let me tell you this i don't
trust anything trump says
so just because trump says a vaccine is
safe doesn't mean it's safe
we have to go through the actual process
that has been very well established
in order to secure a safe vaccine
thanks to jonathan powers whose new
member number 18 today
big thank you to teresa weishans who's
new member number 19.
mary ceruti is new member number 20 on
my website
rose webb is new member number 21. i
know that there's a few more people to
thank i
i will get to everybody also thanks to
oat boy
dark matter the dansky
el pibe de oro who says they're from
norway even though that sounds more like
an argentinian nickname
all of whom have signed up over on
twitch
um let's see
obrego 13 says ilwu local 13 in the
house
wilmington california okay
fernando has signed up richard says
intriguingly there is notably
less negativity about you poor usians
amongst my peers
on this side of the pond stay strong
cousins thanks richard hope to get back
to the uk
as soon as it's safe soon thomas
says people need to understand that
trump literally cannot afford to not be
president
an honest accounting of trump
administration corruption would be too
devastating
for republican politics be vigilant
well said [ __ ] says
shalom david just waiting for this of a
stream
from the first orange american president
it will be bigly and sad yes
and great to see you [ __ ] tommy and
aiden have grabbed
youtube subscriptions so has the duchess
insane lane says please do a piece on
the alaska loophole
and the effect it's having on covet in
canada
keep up the good work well they're
really just doing commercial after
commercial here
this is getting really weird really
really weird
where is trump very strange
luke says thanks for all you do david
appreciate it bigly thank you
thank you anthony
skira says thanks for being a calm voice
other progressive voices get a little
too excited
and it raises my blood pressure all
right well i appreciate that
if you are just joining us just while we
have time uh
a viewer of ours joseph woodward put
together the lo-fi
plasma song i'm sorry plasma i almost
pronounced it correctly there
accidentally
this is the low five today i'm pleased
and
i will be adding uh he sent me a version
without drums i will be doing the drums
on this song uh but this is the version
joseph put together lo-fi plasma it's
just genius guys listen to this
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
beautiful
convalescent strong antibodies from the
blood of recovered patients to help
treat patients battling a current
infection convalescent
loss this is this
if we had a song of the summer this
would be it
operation today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescence
[Music]
that is
anyway so i will be um i will be
recording my
uh track for that uh soon i think i have
uh certain cables i need
coming in today from uh in the mail
which i'll be able to use and and get
that um drum track recorded i think
people are gonna love it i think it
really has a shot at a grammy myself
michael foster sends a super chat and
says speaking of books and screens have
you seen the research indicating five
hours of daily screen time
in adolescence severely affects the
ability to focus
yeah i've i've seen different research
all pointing in that direction
completely i'm on board with that
mike says what is up with the subtitles
no idea
little rock star says much love from our
drummer family to you
love your views and videos i decided to
subscribe today to support the great
cause
thank you and i actually have a few
other subscribers to thank
jeanette andre is a new patron
and number 22 today laura fisher
is number 23 classwistet
is a patron and number 24.
twenty five is rhian cockrell
michelle brillhart is number twenty six
angie haynes is number twenty seven
wesley bates is number twenty 28
claire press is number 29 and you know
as i like to say
let's go for 50. let's go for 50 as we
continue to wait here
bizarrely for a very
very late donald trump
jameson shalpey says thanks for all you
do david
curious on your thoughts or knowledge
about mindful practice and meditation
yeah of course
uh the the the pray the primary book i
would recommend to folks
is wherever you go there you are by john
cabot zinn
sort of uh one of the great voices in
the
mindfulness field discipline i don't
want to call it a movement i think it's
more of a discipline
i would start there start if you're
interested in it start with john kabat
zinn
and my views tend to be very much in
line with his
about it continuing to stand by
for donald trump jeremy says i know
people out there are scared about the
outcome of this election and how it goes
down
but don't let fear lead to bad decisions
peace well said
well said gina says hey david i binge
watched your debates all weekend great
great stuff thanks for all you're doing
thank you i appreciate that
james anktil says hi david here's a five
dollar chat
can you say the following as melodically
as possible uh oh let me look at it
first
take a look it's in a book a reading
rainbow reading rainbow
okay i don't know i don't know about
that
uh henrikh vanderland says
and i thought we have problems good job
keep
going greetings from germany
thank you henrik richard hodgson
says two pounds on witch hunt at six
times
okay so i guess the the sort of side
bets are
trump uses the word hoax four times and
witch hunt
six times can i assign someone the task
of keeping track of that
let me do a few twitch thank yous a jar
of salt
has subscribed with prime el jefe
has subscribed for 14 months
with the message you make these bearable
thank you for doing these my pleasure
um super chat's continuing to come in
but i skipped a few let me see here
where did i leave off um
scrawly tv says can i cameo you
to ask a publisher for the next
translation of a mystery
series ps reads zaragoto
okay here's trump let's see what's going
on thank you happy labors
labor day that was oh wait we have a
different feed
okay no we don't want this one uh here
we go sorry
celebrate the american work we are in
the midst of the fastest
economic recovery oh my god us history
so we have a lot to be thankful for
including let's see if we can get a
better feed
reunion heads and other people they're
very happy with the way things are going
as you probably see the numbers are
terrific
so we called some people wished him a
very happy labor day and they told us
how they're doing and
everybody we really celebrate the
american worker we
are in the midst of the fastest economic
recovery in
u.s history so we have a lot to be
thankful for including this really
beautiful day
so i thought we'd do this outside as
opposed to in
your more normal place the united states
experience the smallest contraction of
any major
western nation you probably know that uh
you look around and see how we're doing
compared to every other nation
it's bad and our rise is spectacular
and we're easy to have a bigger rise
when you have the biggest decline
the u.s economy added 1.4 million jobs
last month
we've added a record-setting 10.6
million
jobs since may 10.6 million jobs
since may that's a record that is the
record is that 45 million
filed new on unemployment claims he's
saying we got 10 million of those back
national budget office was projecting
unemployment over 10.5
percent through the end of 2020 so they
thought 2020 and maybe it would be
a lot longer than that some projections
where you'd go through the entire
year and that includes
a lot of months in the following year
2021
a lot instead the unemployment rate
plunged
really to the surprise of many all the
way down to eight
eight point four percent in august and
that's the second largest single month
decline on record and we have
the first we have both of them so we
have the
two money to talk only about the biggest
increases and ignore that we've had
the biggest decreases it's very strange
seeing the fastest labor market recovery
from
an economic crisis in history world
history
by contrast biden presided over the
worst
the weakest and the slowest economic
recovery since the great depression
remember of course that job growth
slowed when obama and biden left
and trump took over just facts we have
the factor that you need it was the
weakest recovery
under my leadership next year will be
the greatest economic year in the
history of our country i project
and some people are starting to agree we
have a v shape it's probably a super v
super and you see what's going on with
the stock market where it's
uh in certain cases already setting
records
and nasdaq has set 17 records already
and this is
as we're hopefully rounding the final
turn
and the pandemic first we'll
end the pandemic under operation warp
speed
we've pioneered groundbreaking therapies
reducing
the fatality rate 85 since april
man this guy's alpha huh what about a
man very often
uh they don't like to talk about that so
the fatality rate
85 percent think of that since april
the united states has experienced among
the lowest case fatality rates of any
major country in the world and we are
an absolute leader in every way under my
leadership will produce a vaccine in
record time
uh biden and his very liberal
running mate the most liberal person in
congress by the way who's
not a competent person in my income
she's not even the most liberal in the
senate but the idea that she's the most
liberal in congress is laughable
should immediately apologize for the
reckless anti-vaccine rhetoric
that the i literally told you guys
earlier they are going to claim that
kamala's being anti-vaccine all she said
is she wouldn't trump
trust a vaccine on trump's say-so and
you'll have this incredible vaccine and
because of that
fake rhetoric it's a political rhetoric
that's all it is just for politics
because now that's funny is trump is
more anti-vaxxed than anybody
that we've heard from recently like
nobody's ever seen before this could
have taken two or three years
and instead it's going to be going to be
done in
a very short period of time could even
have it
during the month of october so contrary
to all of the lies the vaccine
that they're politicalized they'll say
anything
and it's so dangerous for our country
what they say but the vaccine will be
very safe and very effective and it'll
be
delivered very soon you could you could
have a very big surprise coming up i'm
sure you'll be
very happy oh yeah it's an october
surprise we know he's planning one world
will be happy
next we'll return to unprecedented
prosperity through our pro-american
policies
we'll pass new tax cuts to boost
take-home pay we're
going to be cutting taxes very
substantially we get it back
through growth never get tremendous
growth until we get hit with the china
virus that's what he said
last night we'll continue our historic
regulatory reduction campaign we've
as you know in three and a half years
we've cut more regulations than any
other administration
no matter how long no matter what period
of time you're talking about
will enact fair trade deals and we're
working on
seven major fair trade deals right now
and when i say fair fair to our country
because our country is ripped off by
every nation friend foe didn't matter
every nation was ripping us off
at a level that yeah it's you might
think the u.s is one of the three
superpowers we're the victim globally
guys
in opportunity zones and
we will keep that going it's been a
tremendous
a tremendous program i want to thank
senator scott south carolina for
coming up with that whole concept
because he came up and i liked it right
away and it was it's really turned out
to be a tremendous thing especially for
african-americans hispanic americans
will continue to unleash american energy
we're number one in the world
and we're totally energy independent
right now and in
2021 we'll create 10 million jobs at
least in the first 10 months
joe biden the radical socialist
democrats
yeah nothing socialist about biden you
all know that economy if they got in
they would collapse it you'll have a
crash the likes of which you've never
seen before your stocks
your 401ks remember it's the people that
own these
massive listed companies remember guys
stocks do better under democratic
presidents unemployment is lower under
democratic presidents gp growth is
higher under democratic presidents job
creation is higher under democratic
presidents
i don't know if we care about facts
anymore but those are the facts it will
end everything
including growth there won't be growth
there'll be total contraction
biden's also pledged to demolish the u.s
energy industry and implement the same
policies causing
blackouts in california he wants to have
things
lit up with wind now he'll have to talk
to china
russia india and lots of other countries
because they're not doing that
and if they're not doing it uh it puts
us at a tremendous economic disadvantage
and it doesn't work you take a look at
the blackouts in california it's really
rather amazing what's going on there
they've tried to go and that's just with
a small portion
going that route that doesn't work and
it can't fire up our big plants
if we're going to have this great
industry that we've created can't fire
up our big plants
fire them up biden's plan for the china
viruses imagine 20 coming out and being
like don't vote for the other guy he
likes wind power
somebody to walk up yes sir it's time to
shut it down
he'd be laying off tens of millions of
workers and causing countless deaths
from suicide substance abuse depression
heart disease and other
very serious illnesses because when you
do a shutdown
there's a problem on the other side it's
not just
from the virus you have a big problem
with suicides with losing your jobs with
all sorts of things that you just take a
look depression is a massive problem
what's worse losing a job or dying of
coronavirus i don't know how they how
they scale
substance abuse alcohol drugs
so we can't do that and then we'd have
to give up all the gains that i've been
talking about over the last three months
we've
what we have done is incredible we're
setting records all over the world no
matter where you go nobody has done what
we've been able to do
good so we're setting records and jobs
we're setting records and numbers and
you're going to see some very big
numbers third quarter numbers are coming
out right before a very special day
november 3rd
so you have the numbers coming out and
they're uh
i think going to be fantastic you know i
think they're going to be fantastic
the best numbers of all if somebody
doesn't come along and raise taxes
double triple quadruple your taxes
will be the numbers from how do you
quadruple the 37
tax rate somebody do the math on that
and uh
i think it's going to be hard for even
the media to disparage that number
biden wants to surrender our country to
the virus he wants to surrender our
families to the violent left-wing mob
and he wants to
surrender our jobs to china our jobs and
our economic well-being
i've taken in billions and billions of
dollars from china no other president's
done what i've done
remember that when we tariff china it is
our businesses that pay the tariffs when
we import chinese goods
still trump doesn't seem to understand
that but he's done that we haven't taken
in 10 cents from china
ever they targeted our farmers and i
targeted them
and i gave 28 billion dollars to our
farmers
our farmers wouldn't be existent right
now right now they're very happy in fact
they're setting records on purchases
china is purchasing more corn than
they've ever done
record purchase of corn and soy beans
beef
because they know i'm not happy with
them they know i'm not happy at all
and frankly uh i don't want to set
the world necessarily to thinking too
much about it right now but there's been
no country anywhere
at any time that's ripped us off like
china
has we lose billions and
billions of dollars for years and years
decades
we've lost billions and billions and
billions of dollars by
dealing with china we get nothing from
china they get nothing other than loss
other than giving our money and they
take that money and they build their
military and you see they're building up
a powerful
military and it's very lucky that i've
been building ours up because otherwise
we'd be dwarfed right now by china
it would be a terrible thing a terrible
thing
we're way ahead on the nuclear front
remember guys troops who die
are losers and suckers but we need an
even bigger military to be able to send
more troops more places to die
makes sense huh but china's spending the
money we give them to build up their
military
so when you mention the word decouple
it's uh
it's an interesting word so we lose
billions of dollars
and if we didn't do business with them
we wouldn't lose billions of dollars
it's called decoupling so you'll start
thinking about it you'll start thinking
they take our money and they spend it on
building airplanes and building
ships and building rockets and missiles
and biden has been just a pawn for them
he's been so easy they dream about bite
and there was a report today
they hope that joe biden becomes
president if joe biden becomes president
china will own the united states and
every other country will be smiling also
they'll be smiling
when reports come out that certain
countries don't really like me too much
that's not because of my personality
although it could be that also frankly
right it's because of the fact that i've
been very tough on countries that have
been ripping us off for so many years if
you look at nato
with the exception of eight countries
we're one of them
every country is way behind they're
delinquent especially germany
in paying their nato bills that means we
end up paying it and we're not doing it
i told him we're not doing he sounds
extra like a mob boss today i don't know
what it is 130 billion
going up to 400 billion dollars a year
it's all because of me then you hear the
country doesn't like me i mean i can
understand that
because president obama and other
presidents in all fairness would go in
there and
they'd make a speech and they'd leave i
went in there i looked and i said this
is unfair we're paying for nato
we're paying for nato almost all of it
so they
rip us off almost all of it oh my god
some connection to reality please
and biden doesn't have a clue
he you know he doesn't have a clue
biting everybody knows he doesn't have a
clue
in prime time he wasn't good and now
it's not prime time let's watch the
debates he spent 47 years sending
american jobs to china to mexico and to
other countries while collecting
millions of dollars
in campaign and super pac contributions
from
global corporations that got rich by
making american workers poor
his son where's hunter where's hunter i
call him where's hunter
uh walked away with one and a half
billion dollars to manage even though he
never did that before he walked away
with a fortune from ukraine
from china and from other countries here
we go between his son and his brother
you ought to read the
statements and the press doesn't pick
that up if i ever did that brother
it would be uh it would be hell even
worse than it's been
okay even worse than it's been what he's
done is so incredible
i won't give them the billion dollars he
says i won't give them unless they get
rid of that prosecutor
never voila they got rid of the
prosecutor
and the press doesn't want to talk about
it you talk about quid pro quo
with me there was none with him he's
right on tape and you don't want to
cover it you should be ashamed of
yourselves
that's the new thing attacking the media
telling the media they should be ashamed
shipped away our jobs sick just they now
like
he got that from richard grinnell last
week who showed up and told the press
they should be ashamed of themselves now
trump has done it twice
the top people in the pentagon probably
aren't because they want to
do nothing but fight wars so that all of
those wonderful companies that make the
bombs and make the planes and make
everything else stay happy
but uh we're getting out of the endless
wars you know how we're doing
we defeated 100 of the isis
caliphate 100 when i was in when i came
in it was a mess it was all over
they have it in a certain color all isis
a year later i said where is it it's all
gone sir
because of you it's all gone because of
my philosophy
sir all gone i said that's good let's
bring
our soldiers back home some people don't
like to come home
some people like to continue to spend
money
one cold-hearted globalist betrayal
after another and that's what it was
this is supported
nafta he supported china's entry into
the world trade organization
two disasters the most disastrous trade
deals in history both of them i can't
tell you which was worse they were both
terrible
and as you know i ended it and uh i
ended nafta
and we're looking at the world trade
organization they've become much better
i will say that we uh
world health i got out of because we're
spending 500 million dollars china was
spending 38 million dollars in china
controlled
if trump resigned right now i would
really respect him very nice to us
lately i will say that
amazingly we never used to win anything
at the world trade would lose every case
now all of a sudden we're winning a lot
of cases
we just won seven billion dollars as a
case
and they're talking to us much
differently than they used to
because if they don't shape up we're
gonna ship out that's all we're not
treated fairly
china is treated as a developing nation
developing nation we're treated as
a nation that's fully developed we're
not fully developed as far as i'm
concerned when you look around at
portland and you see what these
democrats are doing to our city
take a look at what's happening in new
york this is an inc it's a verbal
inkblot guy it's a rorschach
china wto portland developing
it's a mess by joe biden badly and
mayor's running cities so badly it's
very sad to look at it
it's democrat run every one of them that
i see
i guess we could probably find one or
two that aren't but i don't
so far i haven't been able to
uh if you look at biden he supported
tpp trans-pacific partnership
which would have been a disaster would
have destroyed
whoa the white house feed just went dead
we'll go i guess we'll switch to another
one this is weird
paris oh my god the audio
it's a disaster for this country they've
basically taken away your wealth
the paris climate accord and the other
countries don't have to adhere to it
china doesn't kick in until 2030 they
don't have to do anything until 2030.
we had very high standards we went ahead
and closed under some scenarios
white house 25 of our businesses in
order to qualify under this ridiculous
paris lineman accord
sounds good it was very bad very
expensive the new york times has just
published an entire story inviting
china's sellouts which is amazing for
the new york times
i appreciate that in 2001 biden said the
united states welcomes the emergence of
a process let's try this other one see
if the audio is better
one of the reasons it's so bad is that
china didn't play by the rules we did
we did but their rules were easier
because they're considered a developing
nation so they had a much lower standard
but even that they didn't play by the
rules that's when they became a rocket
ship
they were flatlined for years and years
and years and they joined the world
trade organization
and frankly they cheated i'll keep
checking together what i'll say what
difference is it i feel much
differently i feel i've made a great
trade deal with china great
and they're buying you know why they're
buying because they know i'm not happy
that's why they're buying
and i talk about it because today is
labor day it's a good time to talk about
when we're being ripped off by
countries but nobody's even close to
china
biden cheered china's rise as a great
power because great powers adhere to
international norms in the
areas of non-proliferation human rights
and trade well they didn't
stupid people and biden's a stupid
person you know that you're not going to
write it
is stupid the cost of biden's economic
treachery was 60
000 shuttered american factories and i
hear this morning the
real number is probably 70 000. 70 000
shuttered american factories and he's
talking about how wonderful it is
with china now china's been very bad on
top of which we had the
china plague sent to us and other
viruses nothing
near this areas but the swine we had
other viruses
sent in over the years that came from
china
i wonder why if biden wins china wins
because china will own
this country if biden wins
china will own this country and
hopefully you're not going to be able to
find that out
it's the most important election in our
history right now
most important election in our history
under my administration
we will make this is particularly
pointless today right it might
i mean it's always meandering but it's
extra weird
whether it's decoupling or putting in
massive tariffs like i've been doing
already
i'm going to end our reliance on china
because we can't rely on china
and i don't want them building a
military like they're building right now
they're using our money to build it
we'll manufacture our critical medical
supplies in the united states
we'll create made in american tax
credits and bring our
jobs back from china to the united
states and will impose tariffs on
companies that
deserve america to create jobs in china
and other countries if they can't do it
here
then let them pay a big tax to build it
someplace else and send it into our
country
we'll prohibit federal contracts from
companies that
outsource to china and will hold china
accountable for allowing the virus to
spread around the world
now you can understand why china would
much rather see sleepy joe than donald
trump
but as long as i'm president we will
never waver in our
undying loyalty to the american worker
and to our country as a whole
so happy labor day everybody
yeah here we go
well if you don't take it off you're
very muffled
so if you would take it off would be a
lot easier
it's better yeah he hates math
some people are having a hard time
believing your denials of the atlantic
story because of what you said about
john mccain in the past
do you understand that and have you
asked
have you asked john kelly to refuse that
story no i don't understand it at all no
because
i've always been on the opposite side of
john mccain john mccain like wars
i will be a better warrior than anybody
but when we fight it where we're going
to win them
and frankly i was never a fan of john
mccain you know that it's been very
obvious i was
but i had to approve his entire funeral
i wanted him to get he deserved
a first class you know it all was
approved by me
to pick up the casket a lot of things
but no i was not
a fan of john mccain because he wanted
the endless wars
and i didn't i thought that the way the
vets were taking care of our great vets
was
not good not appropriate and of course
he took the fake dirty dust he
gave it over to the fbi so this is not
somebody messed with and say
what a wonderful guy so you know what i
lived with him
he lived with me but we had different
philosophies i think my philosophy is
right i think it's turned out to be
right
but i wasn't a fan but i respect people
remember he called mccain a loser and
said he prefers people who don't get
captured
i necessarily have to agree with him and
i didn't agree with him on a lot of
things
the story is a hoax written by a guy
who's got
a tremendously bad history the magazine
itself which i don't read but i hear
it's just
totally anti-trump he's a big obama
person he's a big clinton person
there's hopes he made about the story
it's a totally made-up story
in fact i was very happy to see zach
fuentes came out
and said now he's that's i think that's
number 15. and these are people that
were there
that's the 15th person general kellogg
everybody that was there kellogg knew
what happened
and so i was happy to see that zach came
out and said it's not
true it just came out and uh it's a
disgrace
who would say a thing like that only an
animal would say a thing like that he's
an animal there's nobody that has more
respect
for not only our military but for people
that gave their lives in the military
there's nobody and i think john kelly
knows that i think he would know that i
think he
knows that from me but zach fuentes says
you know work for john
and i think they both know that but zach
came out as you know
today or yesterday last night and said
very strongly that
he didn't hear anything like that even
john bolton came out said that was
untrue now what was true is that we had
the worst weather
right i think it was as bad a rain as
i've ever seen
and it was a fog you literally couldn't
see i walked out i didn't have i didn't
need somebody to tell me
i walked out i said there's no way we
can take helicopters in this i
understand helicopters very well
said no sir that's been cancelled they
would have had to go secret service i
have the whole list
they would have had to go through a very
very busy section
during the day of paris
they would have had to go through the
city the paris police were
asking us please don't do it because
they're not ready when you do that you
need a lot of
time they take days and days and days to
prepare for that
i wanted to do it very badly i was
willing to sit in the car for two hours
three hours four hours i didn't care it
didn't matter and i had nothing else to
do i went there for that i had nothing
he just sat around watching fox at the
embassy
because of the terrible weather and
nobody was prepared to go through
in terms of paris the police
the military and the secret service and
they came out very strongly and said
sir we can't allow you to make this trip
if i wanted to sir we can't allow you
from a safety standpoint they wouldn't
let them it was a phony story
just like the dirty dossier the fake
dirty dossier
just like the russia collusion just like
all of the other phony stories
and there'll be more phony stories but i
do appreciate zach coming out
but zach now is the 15th person that's
denied it
zach now i think also talked about the
weather aspect of it
and he's probably the 14th or 15th
person
remember the story's been quadruply
corroborated i know you guys know that
thank you for the audio
uh
well i think what's happened is the
the toughness these are democrat-run
cities all
and there's no um
there's no retribution there's no they
stand there
they throw things at the people that are
supposed to be protecting something and
nothing happens they throw rocks they
throw cans of
soup they throw kansas associations of
hard objects
rarely does anything happen but i've
told when we have the federal in there
trump is the most anti-chowder president
we've ever had
kill a another man
and they know who it was and you have to
arrest him
you have to arrest him after two and a
half days they didn't arrest him the
u.s marshals went in and it ended up
being a gunfight and the man was killed
but this is a man that had a bad record
and there's a man that killed a man in
the street i mean i witnessed it most
people witnessed it and
the u.s marshals went in they weren't
playing games they can't play games
if somebody is breaking the law there's
got to be a form of retribution
i watch so often when i watch some of
the the areas that we're talking about
now we have rochester
that's again democrat governor democrat
man
all democrats every one of them and it
always willed me
i was with the governor of texas he
looked at me and said i can't imagine
how they allow this to happen
and you know it's different it's
different i could talk about other
governors saying the same thing yeah
please
so we have now over a thousand people
federal
uh in jail we're prosecuting many people
a big thing was when i signed the law
putting people in jail for your
knockdown monuments that was three
months ago there hasn't been a federal
monument knocked down in three months or
even thought about i don't think they've
even thought about it
so that's had a very big impact it's
like the the audio is a disaster there's
sirens in the background
it's what is going on there's people up
there they take nice pictures of
everybody so
we don't even have to bother we can use
the news photos we had a photo right
over there of andrew jackson
the monument he was getting ready and
this guy was a big brave guy and he was
up like this and he was showing off to
all his friends and
he got arrested so did a lot of other
people get arrested
and i would say we have the ultimate
proof now in that case we got there
before they ripped down the statue of
andrew jackson
which is so beautiful which is right
over there but they never got it but
right after that i signed
an order saying you go to prison for 10
years and
as soon as i signed that order that was
the end of the statues coming down but
they have other ideas they
they've got plenty of ideas they're not
at want
for ideas please go ahead mr spun david
spunt from fox news uh mr trump
mr president thank you for taking my
question um
sir you talked a lot about the economy
entitled the economy three weeks ago in
bedminster i asked you specifically
why you have not called democratic
leadership to the white house to meet
with them
if they don't want to meet it's on them
uh a lot of people who are criticizing
you i cover you on the weekends and
stuff
why have you not met with them in person
i mean we're in september there's no
deal
there's no hope of a deal uh we're two
months out from the election
don't say there's no hope why do you say
this what do you know
what can you say what do you know and
let me just tell you i know my customers
that's what i do
i know pelosi i know schumer very well
they don't want to make a deal because
they think it's good for politics if
they don't make a deal this has nothing
to do with anything other than you have
to know who you're dealing with i do
these are people that i don't have a lot
of respect
i don't think they have a lot of respect
for the american people who does he
respect
dealing with and i don't need to
meet with them to be turned down they
don't want to make a deal because they
know that's good for the economy
and if they make a deal that's good for
the economy and therefore it's good for
me for the election in november
november 3rd and therefore they're not
going to make a deal
now if we gave the store away if we
bailed out all of their democrat-run
cities well we give them a trillion
dollars which is the kind of money they
want they want a trillion dollars to
bail out badly run democrat cities
and states whether it's new york or
illinois or
others and they want to bail them out
and we're saying well we're not going to
pay
we're going to try a different speed
real quick that's been recommended to me
maybe we have better audio i would love
it if we did
they're saying well we're not going to
pay that kind of a price in order to
bail this into it we'll do something to
help cities but that's going to have to
rest on its own
and why didn't you do this at the
beginning because they could have done
it at the beginning
so i know who i'm dealing with and i'm
on the phone with
uh mnuchin and with meadows and with all
of these people
constantly you know while they're there
but i also know when it's time to meet
with people i've done very well with
deals okay that's what i do
and i know when it's time to meet but i
don't have to meet them in order to be
turned down and in order for them to
walk out to the sticks
which is the microphones and give you
people a false report of what just took
place in the oval office so
um they don't want to make a deal
because they think that if the country
does as badly as possible
even though a lot of people are being
hurt that's good for the democrats
but david that's a bad thing yeah please
president shouldn't you take the high
road sir
i am taking the high road i'm taking the
high road by not seeing them like when
he called
biden stupid five minutes ago i think
if i thought it made a difference or
would make a difference i'd do it in a
minute yeah go ahead
david jackson usa today my question is
about the durham report which you have
talked about recently
you said let's see what happens now
you've accused people
of committing crimes against you during
the russia investigation
yeah sure don't worry they spied on my
campaign that's right they spotted my
campaign and if they were democrats they
would have been in jail two years ago
they would have been in jail literally
if this side were
the democrats said they would have been
in jail two years ago for 50 years
for treason and other things not
questions many problems
department to indict people over this
i'm not going to say that i have to see
the report i haven't see i purposely
i don't know if that was a good thing
smart thing i don't know
but nobody can complain about it i have
every right to have been very much
involved and maybe someday i'll get
involved in it
they spied on my campaign and that
includes biden and obama
they spied in my campaign trying to
defeat me they wrote up a
fake dossier that has proven to be
totally fake
written 72-hour psych hold necessary
hillary clinton and the democrats
and they use that illegally in the fisa
courts
if we did what they did you would have
many people in jail all right
right now and you have other than the
one agent that admitted his guilt that
he forged documents
we don't have that yet but the report
hasn't been issued yet let's see what
happens but let me just
let me just say something president
obama
and biden sleepy joe he knew everything
that was happening
they were spying on my campaign and they
got caught now let's see what happens
but if this were the opposite way people
would have been jailed they would have
been in jail already right for a period
of at least
it would have started two years ago and
it would if we re-elect this we deserve
really bad things to happen to us
i mean if we're that stupid four then
they created
at tremendous expense the money they
paid is tremendous i'm sure you know the
money that was paid
millions of dollars they created a fake
dossier
a fake dossier proven to be now fake
everywhere
and they used it in the fisa courts
visor guards
that's a crime so far i haven't seen
anybody
have a problem but the report hasn't
been issued yet let's see what happens
with the durham report
but this started at obama and some
people would say and some people are
well but he was the president
like let's leave him alone if it were me
they wouldn't be leaving me alone i can
tell you it's a totally double standard
and it's a
it's a disgrace and if i were a
republican senator and if i were a
republican congressman and we have some
great ones
but we have a lot of them that don't
fight the way that the other side
fights we have much better policy we
have much better
things going for us like borders and
walls and immigration
walls and no sanctuary cities and a lot
they have a lot of bad stuff going on
he's unhappy but they're dirty fighters
and the dirtiest fight of all is the
issuance of
80 million ballots
unrequested they're not requested
they're just sending 80 million ballots
all over the country
80 million ballots non-requested i call
them
unsolicited ballots that's going to be
the dirtiest fight of all
people are going to get ballots they're
going to say what am i doing and then
they're going to harvest they're going
to do all the things
and if you look at the last he doesn't
know what he's talking about
take a look at the races where they've
sent ballots out
take a look at carolyn maloney whose
race should be redone
because she won that race totally
unfairly
to her opponent her opponent did very
well against her right that race should
be rerun
but they declared her the winner because
they heard i found out about it
but take a look at what's happened in
new jersey and in virginia in different
places
virginia it's a disgrace that'll be a
beauty yeah please thank you mr
president if proven true
are you okay with postmaster general
dejoy
and the fact that he asked former
employees at his private company
to make donations to the gop and then
reimburse them are you okay
i don't know too much about it i read
something this morning but i don't
other than that i have to see it it's a
crime uh he's very respected man he was
approved
very much uh by both parties i guess it
was
sort of an approval that took place by
both parties i don't know exactly what
the story is i
certainly know within a short period of
time yeah i just read it for the first
time i read it this morning
tomorrow you could talk about it support
an investigation sir sure
sure and i think let the investigations
go but but uh he's a very respected man
again it was a bipartisan commission
postmaster general is appointed by a
bipartisan commission
and we'll see how that goes but no i i
think he's a very honest guy but we'll
see
honestly thank you mr president go ahead
follow up please if you don't mind if
it's proven to be a campaign finance
scheme
do you think he should lose his job yeah
if something could be proven that he did
something wrong
thank you always they've been looking at
me for
four years they found nothing looking at
me for four years think of it
for four years from the day i came down
the escalator i've been under
investigation by sleeves
and they found nothing they found
nothing
a friend of mine said you have to be the
most innocent honorable man
ever to hold the office of president
think of it they spent just mueller
alone he spent
i guess the real number turned out to be
48 million dollars but whatever it was
many many millions of dollars
it recovered more money than it cost
remember guys democrats looking
they had fbi agents all over the place
they had every and they have no
collusion friends of mine
have said sophisticated friends have
said you've got to be the most innocent
guy
ever to hold this office and there's a
lot of truth to that yeah thank you mr
president
after navalny poisoning chancellor
angela merkel of germany is under
pressure to cancel
nordstrom 2 pipeline from russia to
germany
would you support such a move do you
think the the project should become sure
well i've been
support i've been supportive of that no
one's been tougher on russia than him
nordstrom 2 until trump came along
when i came along i said wait a minute
we're protecting
germany from russia right
nato we're protecting germany from
russia
germany's paying russia billions and
billions of dollars
to get their energy and the real number
is probably 60 to 70
ultimately of their energy is going to
come from russia
and i said this for years that nobody
talks about it one of the many
things between sanctions and all of the
what we've done for ukraine relative to
what the past said they used to send
pillars and we sent
tank busters pillars but i brought that
up a long time ago russia's unhappy that
i brought it up
but you never heard of nordstrom 2
nobody did until i got elected and i
said why is germany making a deal to
give
billions of dollars to russia and then
we're protecting germany
from russia how does that work and then
on top of it germany is delinquent
because they're only paying a little
more than one percent and they're
supposed to be paying two percent and
even the two percent remember the
question was about a pipeline
just remember trump me i got the
countries
of nato to spend one point 130 billion
going to 400
billion dollars a year
think of it 400 billion dollars a year
more
for nato and the purpose of data
primarily is
europe protection against russia now
they can use it for other i guess
and they have a little bit in the middle
east etc etc
but i'm the one that did that anybody
know what he's talking about nobody
talks about that
nobody talks about nordstrom 2. the
answer is
absolutely if they feel that something
happens
but i don't know that germany's in a
position right now
because germany is in a very weakened
position energy-wise they're closing all
their plants they're closing their
nuclear they're closing their coal
they're closing a lot of plants
and they are they have put themselves in
a very bad position
frankly very very bad position yeah
please
[Music]
no i have nothing against john i have
nothing against anybody no
i was very heartened to see that a
friend of his because i know zach is a
friend of his and worked for him
i was very heartened to see that zach
fuentes came out with the statement that
he did i guess late last night
that it was not true
mr president mr president what exactly
is un-american about federal government
training programs that are aimed at
improving inclusivity well we're going
to do a report yeah i fired those people
they're all good
and uh it was a disgrace frankly and
we're going to give you a big report
that's going to make you very happy all
right yeah please thank you darlene
superville ap
you said a moment ago they'll say
anything you were talking about
joe biden and kamala harris and their
comments about the vaccine
you have no they say worse they say
negative
they say negative they let her get the
question out into a negative so that
when we have it and i spoke to the head
of pfizer i spoke to the head of johnson
and johnson i spoke to had the greatest
i noticed trump pronounces pfizer the
pharmaceutical company and
fisa like fisa cora exactly the same way
you're saying as oh wow this is bad news
president trump
is getting this vaccine in record time
by the way if this were the obama
administration you wouldn't have that
vaccine for three years and you probably
wouldn't have it at all
so we're gonna have a vaccine very soon
could she ask the question though very
special date you know what date i'm
talking about
but let me just tell you wait and what
they're doing
because they think it is going fast and
if you
talk to a lot of your sources if you
have sources
if you talk to your sources in the fda
you'll see it's going very very well at
the
their sources both don't exist and are
lying strong unbelievably good
so now they're saying wow trump's pulled
this off okay
let's disparage the vaccine that's so
bad for this country that's so bad for
the world to even say that and that's
what they're saying it but
i watched kamala's poll numbers dropped
from
15 to almost zero and then drop
out even before she ran in iowa because
people didn't like her
and i understand why she will never be
president although i have to be careful
because obama used to say that about me
so i have to be a little bit careful
right but you have to look at her a
little bit more closely because
obviously
she's going to be allowed to ask the
question so you're going to have to look
at her a little bit too closely but
she's talking about disparaging a
vaccine
so that people don't think the
achievement was a great achievement i
don't want the achievement for myself i
want something that's going to make
people better
that people aren't going to get sick
with that includes therapeutics where
we're doing
equally as well therapeutics go ahead
your point is that what they're saying
is that they're saying it for political
purposes yes
you have asserted repeatedly that a
vaccine will be on the market
by before the election no i didn't say i
didn't say they will i said by the end
of the year
no but you're not quoting me he keeps
moving it up i said that vaccines will
be on the market before the end of the
year
he he has said 10 different things so
that it's just like a pick your own
adventure
be developed and fully developed tested
everything else you know we have
30 000 people in just one vaccine right
now under test
in very very highly infected areas so
we're going to be able to get a good
result
one way the other very soon so i didn't
say what you said
what i said is again by the end of the
year but i think it could even be sooner
than that
he just said a few days ago by october
actually could be before november
no i'm saying that because we want to
save a lot of lives the fast
with me it's the faster they just said
it again
with somebody else maybe they would say
it politically but i'm saying it in
in terms of this is what we need we have
to have if we get the vaccine early
that's a great thing
whether it's politics or not now do
benefits in newer
if you're able to get something years
ahead of schedule i i
guess maybe they do but the most
important thing to me is
saving lives it's the most important
thing yeah go ahead in the back
hi um just based on some of your recent
tweets uh do you um you sound so
clear as opposed to everybody else where
they refuse
he's mad that other reporters are
wearing masks why do you object to that
being taught in schools and do you
object to slavery itself being taught
in schools yeah so no i want everybody
to know everything they can about
our history i'm not a believer in cancer
culture the good of the bad if you don't
study the bad you could happen again so
i do want that
subject studied very very carefully and
very accurately
but we grew up with a certain history
and now they're trying to change our
history revisionist history that's why
they want to take down our monuments
that's why they want to
take down our statues i saw something
the other day which was absolutely
horrendous a washington monument they
want to rename it
the d.c committee but the dc committee
is all democrats
abraham lincoln thomas jefferson i mean
we're talking about
this is the big stuff now this is the
big stuff
and they want to rename it they want to
redesignate it they want to take some
down
no we don't do that never going to
happen with me i guarantee you that
isn't even the question well i want to
thank you all and i just want to wish
you a very happy labor day
and we're having tremendous success
whether it's on the vaccines whether
it's on the pandemic
pfizer the plague that came in from
china the china should have never let
happen
because i will never feel the same about
china and i just want to again wish you
a happy labor day thank you very much
everybody
thank you very much everybody you should
be ashamed of yourselves as
very frequently as said what an event
what an event i'm so glad to have been
able to share that beautiful moment with
about 25 000 of you if you are heading
out particularly
on youtube please hit that subscribe
button you'll be notified when i go live
in the future and i would much prefer
you watch these
with with me in our community rather
than
uh you know on the trump page or
whatever so please hit that subscribe
button
on the way out we are so close we are
now
only 11 900 from 1 million subscribers
uh and as people are heading out we will
of course give you
one more look at the new plasma lo-fi
song i will be back streaming soon
take a listen to this my friends today
i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
convalescent
from the blood of flows patients to help
treat patients battling a current
infection convalescence today i'm
pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
[Music]
this
made
is